coming up next would you date a sim a
Sim wouldn't have the confidence to
approach me a simp is not a man it's a
tiger out wow but now you're left over
for him there's a lot of men that won't
cheat on you you just don't want him if
we require marriage to get laid we would
all be married women
I don't agree okay
we hate the toxic and we hate the
manipulative guys why are we sleeping
with them
so the topic today is what do you have
to offer a man that you haven't given
any other man
yeah yeah see they're they're new you're
a seasoned vet
I don't I don't know the answer to that
question honestly
um
I guess
in this stage of my life I can offer
more maturity in my relationship would
you say you haven't offered that before
uh I have but I think with age and time
and experience I've got more mature and
I have a better understanding in
relationships okay
honestly I don't know but um was having
this conversation earlier
since every man is different I feel like
with a different mind I bring something
different to them
so I think it depends on the man
okay
um I think like she said I just think
every man's different all relationships
are compromised getting to know each
other building together understanding
each other so I think at this stage
probably I understand myself better my
non-negotiables my negotiables so I
think like there's more clarity now I
think on my part as to what I would
require or what so what you offer is you
know what you want I know I won and I
know what I would like to gain at the
same time okay go ahead
um I feel like there's nothing I can
offer a man
that he can't already get okay I mean
I've had a child so okay I mean yeah
okay
so um question for the man what would
you guys like a girl to offer you that
you haven't gotten that she hasn't given
to another guy
peace
peace peace of mind I'm telling you I
think after a long day of just working
going to the gym you just want to come
home to peace
I don't know if it's possible or if they
actually exist but yeah and how how
would a girl offer that to you
and did anything and did any of the
answers that they gave sound like
something you would want about that was
of value to you yeah
um
both for their answers okay tell me why
in terms of like
maturing in a relationship I guess if
it's your first relationship you're
going to make mistakes and it's your
first time you're not really gonna
you've never experienced it before and
you're gonna learn from your experiences
and be a better person so it's good to
like for someone to actually be able to
realize right in my first experience I
weren't really doing what I was meant to
or I didn't understand certain things
but now I'm willing to so okay and what
about you same questions well I'm I'm
married so sorry I should say what did
you get what did I get yes uh
yeah oh that's great yeah that was
that's pretty much it but I would say
something similar like peace
okay
um do you wanna
okay okay I didn't you seem like Okay
um
who okay who is the prize men or women
this is what happens when you're a
veteran on the show you're still smiling
I'm still here
um for me
men and women are the price to each
other
okay how
oh
okay you know what I actually don't I
don't accept that answer pick one yeah
pick one men or women someone has to
reach someone someone's a prize
um
in the pursuit
for happiness I think women are the
prize okay
um but as you you kind of cut off my
answer so I can't give you the answer I
wanted to give but in that yeah women
are the prize four men okay what do you
guys think I feel
women all the prize I feel like from a
young age I've always seen the woman
just sits there and the man is always
chasing after the woman so it just looks
like the woman is the prize okay
um
I think
it depends on what stage of life you're
at for me personally I think if you're
gonna go like just we're just looking
right now I would say women are the
prize as in she's the trophy on your arm
you kind of create her as to what looks
good for you you take her out you get
the all of the compliments that's your
woman she's amazing but I think as a
woman I just think
I don't know I feel like it works but
like what she said I just feel like the
age I'm act we should both be apprised
to each other like there should be some
middle ground or I can't expect a man to
do everything same way he I'm very
traditional but we have to adapt to the
to the world that way and if that makes
sense so I think if you just want me to
say yes or no I would say women are the
prize from a young age you're cute your
hair's long you're this you're that
however I think as you grow up you
realize Marvel's values like even
beliefs like do you get it I feel like
those things are all things that
intertwine and will defend will
determine if you're a prize if you're
some people are beautiful but they're
thirsty inside so I have a question you
said you're traditional how are you
traditional if you're not married
because then once you have traditional
outcomes well me personally I think I'm
traditional in terms of my modes and my
beliefs in regards to men and women so
when I say I think I've watched your
podcast before you talk about submission
I know this generation anti-submission
yeah yeah XXX yeah but I believe we're
in a world where men and women are not
equal yes we should be ideally not and I
think that as you get older you just
need to understand yourself I'm not
gonna go in and project myself into
someone's son I need to have my stuff
together but it's psychologically
spiritually financially in check and
then we can do it together I don't think
there's a Time form or you could also be
traditional get married and then get
divorced so at the end of the day I just
think well I would say if I got divorced
I wouldn't be traditional then like
because to me like the traditional
traditional outcomes you're married with
kids like I don't think you can say
you're traditional no that's the end
goal 100 yeah but I'm saying like until
you have traditional outcomes how can
someone claim to be traditional fair
enough you know I mean I'm not saying
I'm traditional either like I'm not
okay I sorry I I believe that in the
beginning the woman is the prize so as
in in a woman a woman has her prime
stage
and then when she gets to a certain
stage in her life it switches over and
the man becomes the prize so like when
women become
um like I'd say from about 40 onwards
okay
yeah it switches over and the men become
the prize and the women are not so much
the price it's a good answer okay what
do you guys think men or women
Enterprise I'm not gonna lie I'll be
honest at all stages you think men on
the Press pretty much
not even in a way like to say oh I'm 100
let me say why yeah because as a guy
right now
at my age and even in all of our ages
especially like us guys in our 20s
I don't feel like there's what prize
like what do I get from being in a
relationship right now for me personally
in in this current market right now if I
go out with a girl she's gonna get dates
she's gonna get driven around wherever
she's gonna go on holidays what do I get
what kind of woman are you looking at
yeah no but okay
what can he get that he can't get from a
hooker and a maid love yeah
what is it what is what does that mean
because a lot of times when I ask girls
is they give like broad statements
without specifics so could I could I
have something specific yeah um so
you're saying that you're gonna date her
take her on holidays I mean a stupid
generally yeah good stuff yeah generally
yeah there's no woman on this planet
that will get all that good stuff and
not give you love
we're not virgins anymore
like except September
Church guys question was you a virgin
when you married your wife no okay okay
the average age of first marriage in the
UK is 31 so we don't have the youth
anymore
and the Purity so like what what do they
get so I think you can get the better
end of the stick which is what makes us
the prize we're going I was gonna say
all right you're saying the hookah all
of that in my in my mind yeah yeah apart
from sex all of that yeah in my head I
feel like you would have um you know
women aren't nurturing well most women
hopefully you would have that like I'm
talking whether it is
um psychological you know you have
people that are your friends before you
get into relationships that friendship
that whole like being there for you ever
is through a mental breakdown that
sincerity of not using you for what you
have I feel like that is what you
potentially would get from a sincere
person if you get what I'm saying from a
friend though like my guy friend okay
but I'm saying what I'm saying like like
that's a woman's point of view because I
think that's what you would want is like
sincerity from a guy but like so a lot
of times like well as girls when we
think about what we want like we
projected under what guys want they just
they kind of just want us to shut up
you know I think most
I think for most men so like the average
men
um I think women are the prize because
supposedly a lot of men don't get women
so yeah I think women will be the
practice however I think the highest or
like the most optimal prize would be a
man because most like they they tend to
skew the market a bit more because like
like Kevin Samuels is his like version
of a high value man or what have you
they seem to be the biggest prize that
you could possibly get in dating power
of I think for most men
women are the prize because they don't
get women anyway that makes sense well
wouldn't you say those guys don't ever
get a woman like because one out of
three are virgins or haven't had sex in
the past year yeah so that's why I would
say like yeah if those type of guys go a
woman they would feel like they got a
prize yeah but I don't really think they
ever get into relationships like to me
it's like there's two types of guys
there's a guy that's always getting
girls and then there's the second one
that gets their leftovers at 30.
well I think also it's about Confidence
from the man's perspective of being a
lot of men in this Society are not
empowered and given confidence to step
forth as men they're kind of they're
battened down to the female perspective
of you know I feel and because I feel
this you must basically accommodate
those feelings and so so sorry finish
that's what you're saying men were
allowed to have the confidence as men in
their masculinity there would be more
space for them to actually pursue women
a lot of men don't know how to talk to
women they don't know how to approach
women because everything's offensive or
you know why are you looking at me well
you dress a certain way I want to look
nice I want guys to look at me when the
guy looks at you why are you looking at
me you get what I mean and so how are
Men supposed to feel confident when 80
when women find 80 of men is
unattractive not okay or whatever they
they literally think they're
unattractive and then there's another 10
that they find uh okay maybe here or
they're in the last 10 that they'd go
first well it's not first of all biology
natural selection the problem yeah but
like how would you feel if they found 80
of women unattractive it'd be kind of
hard to you know feel confident in
yourself I guess if you have
externalized way your confidence comes
from I think when you build confidence
within yourself and you know who you are
then you step out into the world as a
confident man EG I'll give you an
example and
let's say I don't like to give this
example box for example future to me
he's not a confident man but he projects
confidence into the space where women
will be like oh he's got money you sure
he's made some bold moves involvements
yeah what do you have to be confident to
project confidence huh like what do you
have to be confident to project
confidence because you can have loads of
some degree at all no no no okay you can
use that you so projecting confidence to
attract women's attention and actually
getting women are two different things
yeah but what is self-assem self-assem
doesn't exist
what do you mean like there's no way to
measure it there's no like self-esteem
isn't real it's just like a thing that
the left says well it is no there's no
there's no statistical way to measure
self-esteem
okay there's no way to measure
self-esteem but there's a way to measure
measure our behaviors right okay and
behaviors coming from men with low
self-esteem EG we call them simps we
call them all kind of funny names now if
you're in a reader where women are
dominant and they're allowed to say and
do as they wish which we have right now
we have platform social media Etc
a lot of men will shy away from their
true self just to appease the women in
the arena because I agree as a man you
want women to attract you it's a natural
thing is your biological things you get
what I mean so a lot of guys don't have
they don't know how to talk to women
I've experienced it and I've seen it but
I think it's hard for a man because when
you think about it like they're they're
told if they approach a girl the wrong
way their girl can cry as a yeah and so
how are they going to be confident when
they're told many many from the
time they're 12. how did the other men
do it how did The Confident men do it
well because because
um we have a smaller and smaller
percentage of men screwing all the girls
so again women find 80 of men is
unattractive and they only swipe right
five percent of the time on dating apps
so the reason the dating Market's kind
of effed up right now is because four
girls that are fours five six and sevens
are sleeping with the eights nines and
tens and they think they're on that
level and they're not and they're
rejecting the guys that are on their
level because a guy is willing to sleep
with anyone right so but that doesn't
mean that doesn't that doesn't mean
you're that hot why is our open market
that's the difference if you have time
for me
you have to remember that women are also
breaking up the homes so the men that
would that would traditionally raise
other men to become men are no longer
there because as we know about 80 to 90
of women that leave or divorce their
husband for the primary reason being
financial reasons and the second being
um infidelity but infidelity doesn't
matter because we cheat at similar rates
so most women are leaving the men
because of financial reasons and then
these men are now raised by women and
then they try to chase women but women
don't know how to court women so then
these men are left thinking okay my mom
told me to be nice and buy her flowers
and then she looks and then she he tries
to do that for the girl she's like the
coolest waste man yeah oh and how are
they supposed to feel confident if they
didn't have a man to like raise them I
agree with that I agree with that I
agree with you I do agree with you as
you know when it comes to masculine
confidence it's best it comes from a man
be it your dad beat your uncle whoever's
available to you and as a woman who has
had a strong relationship with her dad
it makes you a different type of woman
on the market you have a different level
of confidence you have realist more
realistic expectations towards men
um you know there's certain things that
my dad helped me understand as a woman
I'm I'm more forgiving than women in my
age group when it comes to not forgiving
that's the wrong word but
I have a better understanding of the
hardships that men face and I have a bit
more empathy towards their position do
you get what I mean but at the same time
having that understanding with a a group
of men who haven't had that nurturing is
still very difficult I've got a question
for you then would you date a simp
wouldn't have the confidence to approach
me
your sympathetic of their position and
obviously you're being raised by your
father if that's had an influence on you
so would you date a Sim being
sympathetic well first of all in my
opinion a simp is not a man it's a it's
a title ouch wow no no he's not a man in
my opinion like if you don't have a
diagram oh sorry if you don't have
certain attributes then you're not on my
radar so for example I'm not a
materialistic person I don't look for
someone with nice clothes nice things
blah blah but I do look for a man who
has logic Direction knows how so is your
answer now yes no I wouldn't date a Sim
okay right but like if you're
sympathetic to the plate of math I
didn't say sympathetic I said empathy
empathetic okay empathetic why wouldn't
you date a Sim yeah I wouldn't there's
no there's no compatibility there for me
I know that a man with logic Provisions
knows what he's about would fit better
with me so that's why so
um question do you guys think that women
date up or down up up I think depending
on age
okay so then then what you say up I say
would you guys say up up yeah
so how can we say women are the prize if
they date up and mandate down that's a
good question that's a great question do
you know that's an amazing question I
feel like the generation we're in now I
feel like everybody just has the day up
because no no everybody can't no so so
this is
someone someone's reaching every relay
relationship someone likes the other
more exactly someone's reaching
someone's settling yeah okay yes indeed
I genuinely feel like where we are in
this life here
everything is so difficult yeah
everything is getting worse and worse
just it's not check your friend zone
yeah
wow that was a good thing yeah I feel
like my guy friends are compatible as
friends and I'm not and I don't want to
lose that no no no you're not attracted
to them like that or something if you
like the attention you like the
attention I think I'm definitely
attracted to some of my guy friends I
just wouldn't want to go there would
they want to go there with you
possibly however I just know that the
boundaries and above are treasure the
Friendship I'm not trying to do that
yeah because more time if a relationship
ends up bad I've lost you as a friend
yeah and as that and if I value the
friendship I feel like but it can end up
good what the relationship that's the
risk in it it sounds quite pessimistic
do you really see yourself having a lot
of male friends once you get married is
that really help no no yeah so healthy
That's not healthy That's not healthy
so what's the point of having them
around no but I just feel like I like in
this day and age like you have I feel
like a lot of people are mad so what do
you what do you what do you see as the
problems in the dating Market the
problems in the dating Market I feel
like um everything has become so what
can I get what can I get materialistic
and I feel like people aren't looking at
character anymore do you think that's
the men or the women I think is both so
you think it's the matter also the women
I feel like women have become this which
means that the men don't even care
anymore it's like if you want them for
maybe materialistic things that quite a
few women so it's kind of like if that's
all you look at me for then all right
cool I'll take you your sister your
auntie and then could you explain that
more what do you mean so what I mean by
that is there's a lot of guys who let's
say faithfulness was something that
let's say 10 years ago was key right now
in this generation it's like nobody
cares or quite a few people don't care
if the guy is faithful or not as long as
he's looking after them so you've got a
lot of men who maybe they were faithful
growing up now it's like I don't even
need to be fair because I can get the
test yeah is that the fault of the men
or the women support of the woman yeah
yeah I agree with you oh yeah sorry I
genuinely believe it's the fault of the
woman because it's like if you hand them
a silver platter why would they not take
it yeah and why do I need to be faithful
um um spiritual distance
so why did you say women are the prize
then because when you're growing up like
I said from a young age you're pretty or
this or that I think when you get to a
certain age you need to understand you
need to understand the flower of your
youth when it's finished darling
understand this Village however I feel
like
um naturally you're taught today up
because I just feel like
he just needs to be the head of the
household if that makes sense so the
head would mean he's up yeah so then he
would be the prize yeah but that's
something my answer was when you get to
a certain age I feel like it flips
me okay I think let's say 25 and up 25
and up 25 hours I think off to high
school I'll be honest no I agree with
you what would you think I I think I
think men are always the prize because
because the women the women that men
want like when 50 of women that hit 30
are single and childless so so the most
that you think men understand they're
the prize from Young I think I think the
small percentage of men do when they
have when they have other doorstep
like from from the time they're from the
time
kid you know because it's only a very
small percentage of men that get that
and then you know the the women
like the women that won't settle and I
think they're just gonna die alone
no seriously because yeah and they won't
have kids and but fulfill their
biological imperative so you have to
compromise that yeah I mean somebody
willing to though yeah but this is the
thing like we compromise where it always
benefits us and never benefits the man
because when we compromise it's like at
30. literally and that's not what men
want um
when you talked about the dating Market
the old women on the panel believe that
women are the problem in the with the
dating Market
they contribute they contribute 100 they
contribute because there's one can I
just say this yeah there's more women on
the market in the dating market and how
I would put it is everyone so a lot of
women say they're the prize but they
don't act like a prize so they're
readily available if you're available to
25 men how are you a prize you're
readily available I put it like this if
you have a Rolex they don't advertise
Rolex you know the value of it if you
see a Ferrari they don't advertise that
you know the value of it if you're on
socials dating apps advertising yourself
with no clothes you know trying to get
male attention are you really a prize
but what that sounds
that sounds like a cognitive distance to
me so like you think one thing but
you're not the other so that still goes
back to the fact that women are
potentially the problem in the data
market because of this delusion that
they they carry I'm the prize yeah I
deserve this and I deserve that yeah
really I'm not actually the price like
how can you be a prize at all if you're
a virgin if you're not a virgin
in the 1950s like like you were a hoe If
you if you slept with like two people I
think men nowadays would pray for two
and so it's like like how are you a
prize if you're not a virgin and so
you're well the first of all sorry the
social parameters have changed okay we
know this and we're acknowledging that's
the case here in this but men haven't
changed just because the social
parameters but the thing is the social
the social parameters have changed to
appease women yeah and so so but men
have remained the same they they want
the same things women have changed no
but as I said the social parameters have
changed so the social parameters for men
have changed and the social parameters
for women have changed what do you mean
what do you define social parameters so
for example
materialistically men are supposed to
still provide be able to provide at a
higher rate and to faster rate from a
younger age this is the social parameter
change it's not realistic it is set up
by women I agree but with the women with
the ladies now a lot of us we have a
materialistic approach to how we view
men and when they can't provide that we
get upset we don't actually look at like
what you said the characteristics the
moralistic values we don't look at
actually when I look at this man do I
see family because a lot of people
they're they're they want uh Financial
benefits but they don't actually want
family what doesn't that make women the
problem then yeah it is because men are
the same like if anything more is
expected of man is less is given to them
no go ahead I think that um we're
getting married a lot later in life and
that's you know part of it so like for
example maybe 50 years ago getting
married at age 16 to 18 might not have
been a big deal whereas now whether when
a a young woman wants to get married at
21 it's like are you ready for this you
know have you finished uni yeah have you
traveled there's there's so much that
women are doing that they weren't doing
50 years ago that they're doing now and
it's affecting the the age that people
get married so doesn't that make women
the problem
I said where the prize when we're
younger oh yeah yeah before 40. and I'm
curious I haven't heard much from you
what do you think because I don't agree
okay that's a problem okay oh great tell
me why tell me why because I'm young
isn't it so I'm just thinking when I was
younger women were always the one
um more involved in the relationships
men were always the one cheating
cheating the woman wrong so that now I'm
21. all of us are tired at the age of
20. why did you pick them
if women hate being cheated on why'd you
pick the ones that cheat girls no you
know early on that they're gonna cheat
on you you know you know damn well you
know you know you know you know damn
well you know damn well that that guy is
capable of cheating so how that's how is
that on him when you picked him do you
know what after I finished with the guys
that cheat I was not like let me go to a
nice guy even now you're but now you're
a leftover for him oh but I was only
like 18 so yeah look at I'm not saying
I'm just saying that's how men view it
18.
I don't know I'm not gonna ask like what
I'm just saying like I'm saying this is
common so so you're young but I'm saying
this is common where girls will go
through the bad boys and the cheaters
until they're 27 28 and then come to the
nice guys who they've been rejecting the
last decade right and saying take me oh
I'm ready for you and they're like well
now your Chad's leftovers
and I say that but it's like how is that
on them when we pick them because one
out of three men are either virgins or
haven't had sex in the last year so
there's a lot of men that won't cheat on
you you just don't want them
or go to go to you guys don't have time
do you guys have Taco Bell here you do
yeah here we go to go to Taco Bell ask
the guy out behind the counter I bet you
he won't cheat on you come on don't do
that go ask him out
don't we feel like back in the day there
was no social media like they were
writing letters everyone's covered up
from head to toe I feel like because now
there's more Temptation even for the
guys because women because yeah because
women got worse yeah because because
when men will do anything to get laid
okay literally anything so if if we
require marriage to get laid we would
all be married
I would say women have thrown it at them
yeah like we're less valuable to men
because men are the same can we ask the
men that what's valuable to them that
would be yeah go ahead go ahead
like what do you mean like what what
does value mean to you in a woman
uh femininity uh submission
um
being my piece
P1 yeah it's so important I love that
one yeah that's it yeah I would say
literally the same stuff as them like
literally the same um being feminine
peace of mind
um being able to look at yourself as
well and have self-development like be
able to actually say yeah accountability
yeah you know what I mean being able to
have a conversation about stuff like if
there's an issue which some a lot of
people can't do to be honest so also
question do you guys value purity
have a girl that slept with 100 guys or
one guy
I'm not even talking to you okay okay
let's let's say would you rather have a
girl that slept with 10 guys or 50.
you know what's crazy
um that you're talking about period I
went into someone's Tick Tock live but
it's about purity and she was talking
about Andrew Tate and you know he says
the same kind of thing yeah with girls
sleeping with loads of people and they
go sleeping with less
um and she said well I don't really care
what guys think I'll sleep with whoever
I want and as much people as I want
there's nothing you could do about it in
my head I just thought this is the
problem because I don't know if there's
like something I'm not mad but they will
still get laughed so yeah but no I don't
agree with it I agree with that one I
think that's where we attacked but
that's crazy but those kind of girls but
those kind of girls I feel like I I
strongly disagree it's mad because you
get like let's say I've seen good guys
that will go for that and I'm just
saying like what I'll tell you why
they're the nice guys picking up the
leftovers and the problem is those girls
don't respect him because they actually
want the dude that cheated whenever
whenever a girl whenever a girl has a
guy that she always complains about
that's who she loved the most
it's not it's not the one that she
doesn't really talk about he said he was
such a good boyfriend he said she didn't
like him you're laughing you know it's
true
and so those guys picked them up at 30
and then they'll still cheat with the
the guy they really wanted or wish they
were with him yeah what dumb fool
but that's cool that's why that's why
like virgins should be preferred like if
you if you slept with one person and you
get married what is your chance of a
happy marriage do you think
but then do you know what I find Crazy
that yeah you also get the guys that
complain that all my day she didn't know
what she was doing in bed and then now
he started cheating five years down the
line because she's so dead and also no
wait no way no way no I've heard the guy
say we actually weren't sexually
compatible that's the reason why because
he was probably too much of a freak most
girls can't have good sex seriously gosh
most girls are not good at six how did
you know uh-huh
no honestly most girls just take wood
let's be real like but if it's your
partner would you not teach them and
would you not
would you like not like growth like as
in you're teaching her what you like
she's teaching you what she likes of
course it's contextual
um I don't think you can be the partner
and not expect her to lack certain
things but then that's what I'm saying
to certain guys they're just overly
freaky because most men are very simple
to please just block them it's true but
guys would prefer a girl they could
teach yeah versus because if she's
coming in a freak she's like where did
you learn that
where are you
you're so funny I have this discussion
about my Mo cousins my brothers I feel
like every guy says listen I'll be right
Men Are from Mars Women Are from Venus
one of my favorite books men are so
simple well what you like say peace of
mind when they don't want to talk just
leave them he will come back when he's
ready and I feel like because we're so
emotional and erratic sometimes it's
like you know how men are quite logical
when you call your man of a problem we
just want to hear um is it is it is that
the reality most times we're not doing
well because of our nature we don't we
try in our heads we're like like me for
example
I feel like I can be very peaceful I can
be very understanding but there are
times in the month where I'm not I'm
just not having it because of my I don't
know maybe I can blame it on the
hormones or or that day is just not the
day or I'm in my head about something
that he's done as much as I want to be
peaceful I might not be peaceful that
day and so I feel like somebody then it
wouldn't be your character
I'm not saying that it's it's good that
I'm like that I know that it can be a
problem but relationships are never
perfect you know what I mean I could
control that at work right I I can and
the thing is I do control it in my
relationship as much as I can there's no
relationship that doesn't have fights or
arguments you know what I mean so but
sometimes you go from zero to 100 and
you know you've as long as you
acknowledge you've done it and you're
able to apologize and accept
accountability you try and change that
is quite interesting because like um
Phil said you can for most women you can
stay quiet at work but at home you're
letting loose like why is that I mean
you have to communicate with someone
your boss have more power than you it
depends on what you call it a new some
women are mad and It's Shouting and it's
throwing plates I mean we see it on
social media we see movies and stuff
like you know some women do throw things
around the name of Jordans smashing
phones smashing cars we see that yeah
but a lot of women are not doing that
and also can I say something before you
got with that women I'm gonna lie you
should have seen her in all her Seasons
when I say Seasons I mean how she's
reacting to like how she's talking when
she don't know that you're watching how
she's dealing with a certain situation I
understand some women are tapped some
men are attacked but I also feel like if
you're getting with a woman you should
try and see her you don't always see it
though you you won't even I think I
agree but I feel like you can see
everyone in their Seasons you just have
to I think in modern generation a lot of
us lack self-awareness 100 yeah so and I
think that is more
um more women lack self-awareness for
that I'm gonna say that just because
of the situation we're talking about how
prevalent are they you don't really see
men going out there and doing Mad stuff
like that you see women doing that more
so I speak on it if you didn't disagree
I agree with you I'm an expense
that's what I was gonna say it's
promoted to perpetuate to perpetuate it
further and to empower people who don't
have the understanding so for me it's
not about me but being self-reflective
is a part of day-to-day Life as a
partner to somebody else if you can't
reflect on your own behaviors you
shouldn't be on in a relationship what
do you mean by self-reflective what
actionable items is that so if for
example you have a disagreement with
your partner okay you should be able to
communicate how how that came about what
because men they use less words together
they don't want to hear a whole load of
talking let's be honest they just want
to get straight to the point what can I
do to be a better partner to you in this
situation communicating that to your
partner because you're the you're the
second in command if you want to say
your your man is a representation of you
and you are a representation of your man
when he's not around and when he's
around obviously do you think that's
what men want
do you think they want like constant
communication
well I will say I don't know what men
want but I will ask them I don't assume
anything I'm going to ask you every man
every man is different what say for
example what Devonte requires and what's
your name
Phil Phil what Phil requires maybe
totally different spectrums you know
Phil's married to his wife she's got
maybe not I don't know but maybe she's
got six attributes of maybe the 10
attributes he really loves and that is
good enough and he can work on that but
if you don't if you're not
self-reflective as a as a woman and a
man together
I think I think we may not have to be
self-aware in today's society because
because of the accountability element so
look there is no impetus throughout your
life as you're growing older for you to
have to be self-reflective and
self-aware because
if you're attractive most men give you
everything you want you can get it
there's no need there's no need for you
to have to think okay how do I behave in
this context or that context I think
that comes with maturity Give an example
I was talking to a girl and she's very
attractive and I told her most of the
girls around you are with you because
you're pretty and also the guys that
chat you just want to you but to
her she just thought this is all
everybody loves me everybody loves me so
at what point in her life does she
realize that she's being used and by the
time she's able to realize by where
she's mature she's already beat out by
Bare man so where's her value
why do women always think they're tans
in my life had a man say I'm a 10. you
know I mean I'm honest I feel like if my
like if I don't look nice my diaphragm
will say you don't look nice like change
that I go oh girl you look so cute so I
feel like men accept the reality and
they're not gonna lie to you you have to
you might not you sorry a person X might
be really minus one however her
girlfriends because of mental health and
like a lot of things they might just be
like you're really beautiful right now
but that goes that goes back to the
point that women don't face reality I
feel like the women who say that their
tens don't really believe they are
anyway when you when you see how they
behave they don't behave like they
believe their turns they're just saying
it because of what they can get but the
point is they can go out in society and
be delusional yeah like and that's
that's normal for women and women women
are built out of every single bed
decision we make can I just can I just
say about the 10 business most of the
women that lie to their friends and say
their friend is a 10 knowing she's a
free Allah sorry
that happens because it allows those
women who also feel that they're a three
and a four yeah or maybe a five or a six
feel bolstered up in that group do you
understand feel like the beautiful
friend like oh yeah girl you look good
but when you go out like your friends
looking a bit tacky and you feel a bit
more attractive
that's a dynamic in in play so they're
more desirable to mend it's indirect is
it insulting for a woman to be called
average
honestly if you're average your
personality might be like out of this
world but the reality is to the human
eye or to whoever is telling you are
average that's their opinion I don't
think there's anything wrong with
preference you might be um like 10 out
of 10 to me you might be five out of ten
someone else it's just and you can't but
that's a female like you're not a 10 out
of 10 to anyone if you're ever talking
but then you can't take what someone
else says if you are averages you know
your average go and work on yourself or
believe in your average
but I'm saying most people are average
so like oftentimes if I tell a girl
she's average they get defensive they're
mad because it has a negative
connotation but just tell them fix up
and use your brain
what is a three what's the ten let's
clarified okay perfect okay what are the
what are the things that make people
these robots that's what I was talking
about like women's primary value to the
world is your looks that's the most like
valuable asset that you can see every
year when they show the most handsome
man exactly and I'll just be like he's
all right I don't think he's all that
but scientifically when you go out and
ask people yeah because you find because
you find 80 of men unattractive that's
why you think that no I think that's all
right it's just not my type that's why
like that's why you can find the most
handsome man on the planet
you you keep interrupting me stop and
you could find a guy in the top five
percent of of male handsome and you
still find him ah he's all right and
like that's that's that's women that's
true women do we do let's be real we do
it no we're having someone so nicely she
might do even when you see someone with
their boyfriend you'll be like um I'll
tell him he's nice no no no you see
someone with that book so you don't get
the boyfriend's mind no I'm saying if I
think someone's nice I believe no no if
you don't think someone's boyfriend is
nice
the reaction what's your reaction at
least he treats you nice
to answer your question I say eight to
ten means you can get a modeling
contract eight is it you're the
prettiest girl in a small town nine
means you're going to Hollywood based on
your looks alone 10 is damn near perfect
seven I go off of Kevin Samuel's scale
so I don't do sevens because people are
either models or they're cute pretty
five is normal six is cute below that
okay
but yeah that's that's how so but a lot
like on Tick Tock the other day
um
I I got banned but before I got banned I
commented on a girl because she was
going off on my things and I just said
another average looking girl coping oh
man because she was
because she she was mad because I was
saying men prefer younger women it's
just true it's not fun I don't enjoy
that I'm getting you know I'm 25 I'm
gonna be 26 in November I don't enjoy
that but it's just true and if you're
average looking at 30 you're below
average
but you know she but like that's in it
but do you see everyone silent because
that's an insult but it shouldn't be
it's not anything
because the insults even if I said
average looking guy no one really yeah
I'm actualizing a man once I agree with
you but yeah yeah it's so crazy because
it's like men want maybe what's younger
than them maybe because you're bendable
you're movable is that you're teachable
whereas when you're older you're
probably more stuck in your ways and
also you're probably prettier because
you're younger unless you just don't
look your age that shouldn't be the case
people people do lie because if if you
walk around you believe you're 10 and
you're like I'm a 10 I'm a 10. people
are going to shut you down and say no
you're not but if you go around saying
I'm a two that would also try and pump
you up and say no you're not even a two
you're five that's true most people
don't want to be honest about what they
really think because they don't want to
hurt feelings
I think if women really got that
pushback there wouldn't be so many
claiming their turns that's true so I
don't think I think that's true but if a
man goes on social media and he says I'm
a town of Montana I swear to God women
will be the first ones even even you
this is the most handsome man on the
planet for a magazine
and your first comment isn't it he's all
right and it's I'm no hate to you it's
just part of like women but my thing is
yeah we're not all going to think
attractive is attractive that's my point
do you know what I think it is as well
some for women's I thought for me let me
speak for myself like when when I if I
see a man and I don't think he's
attractive or my type my mind could
change when I start talking to him or
when I get to know him or see his Vibes
I think sometimes because women don't
see looks first if he's feminine he
starts talking like a girl and he don't
like women sorry you don't like women if
he's talking to me
have you ever had a guy who's very
attractive then he opened his mouth and
he like sounds like a girl and his voice
is so high pitched and you're like oh
God
I'll assume he's a I can't say it coming
um okay so if so going back to the prize
analogy
if women date up and they claim they're
the prize
and she is the prize in a relationship
then isn't that relationship destined to
fail
so if women if women claims that she's
the prize isn't that relationship
destined to fail because women date up
hmm
I don't want to speak first because okay
you're quiet I feel like you got it yeah
I'm King I'm not sure
I just think the man is the head I feel
like the man is the head the woman is
the neck we all work as one so women
don't actually know how much power they
have in regards to like you could get a
man to do something just by maybe
advising or changing the way you speak
and it can be done so if we're going
technically I would say yeah because for
her to be what was the context of of the
question so if she thinks she's the
prize already
I already think that we need to
understand that the man
you see the word prize is a bit have you
okay have you ever seen a girl that like
genuinely feels like she married down oh
and like like that she she runs the show
she is her husband by that it's like she
she walks all over here does that does
that like it's horrible to see I don't
like that because I feel like the man
like he's just disrespectful when he
when he puts her on a pedestal yeah like
Will Smith remember a couple I called I
called Will Smith before any when he was
remember at all the awards shows girls
don't like that they don't respect that
but in that relationship she she he felt
like she was the prize and now and now
you have one of the a guy in the top one
percent of looks money
I think it used to be muscles sorry but
like
looking stupid he looks like a fool
because of his woman the whole like that
relationship has failed then
100 oh yeah and you're saying that's
because she because he looked at Jada as
depressed she gave her the control right
well partially yeah because she like
Jada Jada wanted to be with a Tupac and
that and so and that's what that's what
that's when we go back to the bad boys
and the nice guys well because he picked
a girl he picked a girl that had been
ran through by by Tupac yeah maybe he
wanted to do that he got time he got two
pucks leftovers
so I think you mentioned something where
you said um
it was along the lines of you guys have
basically gassed up the girl
to make like you said she thinks people
like her but they don't it's just her
looks so therefore you guys have played
that role but I was also going to say
you know how the women the term women
are mad I think we are visibly more mad
because we act out I also think there
are some guys whether it's narcissistic
Tendencies or psychological they may and
it's not seen on social media or it's
not seen out there all we see is the
woman going mad the woman burning shoes
the woman doing this but I feel like
sometimes you get a lot of Mad Men who's
true I don't know what they studied but
they get into a woman's head and it may
not be like he's actively doing
something but those men were raised by
women
I'll tell you that now those men were
raised by men with those Tendencies
you're talking about the acts of
manipulation to get into your head and
that's what women do that's what women
do to their husbands that's what women
do when they have kids
that's women so the men you're talking
about goes back to women are angry woman
and at the end of the day women are in
control of relationships I know men get
to pick who they're in a relationship
with but you could argue that women are
in control because we're in control sex
and these days that seems to come first
so we're picking so if we we hate the
toxic and we hate the manipulative guys
why are we sleeping with them
Ties on a daily basis on this platform
if you want to help please consider
sending a super thanks below every
donation helps and it helps make what we
do possible